[Music]
so how's your summer season going i've
been having fun with a lot of shows that
i knew unlike entering the season and i
found some shows that are big surprises
too you know those shows that didn't
catch your eye too much at first but
ended up being one of the favorites in
the season but we're not here to talk
about summer as much as i'd love to
spend time talking about the current
season and raving about my favorites
that's gonna have to wait for another
day because today we're talking about
yep you guessed it the top 10 most
anticipated anime for fall 2021 but hey
before we move on to the big hit of this
fall i'd like to thank crunchyroll for
sponsoring today's video crunchyroll as
you may know is one of the biggest
contributors to anime streaming boasting
over 30 000 episodes in their catalogue
both in subs and dubs now they're proud
to present their newest creation fenner
pirate princess fenner pirate princess
is a crunchyroll and adult swim original
created by production ig the studio
responsible for some fan favorites
including psychopaths and ghost in the
shell fenner pirate princess is an
action adventure story with a hint of
romance it stars fenner an orphan who
escapes from a life of servitude into an
isle of samurai pirates there she
discovers the truth about her family
before taking charge as captain of the
samurai crew in a quest to uncover
unimaginable treasures danger lurks in
every corner as she embarks on a high
seas adventure to remember personally
speaking the show is a big surprise why
well i was simply blown away by how good
everything looks from the crisp
backgrounds to the soundtrack for one of
my favorite personal composers yuki
kajira the show's as beautiful as it
gets in the production department it's
the perfect fit for such an upbeat and
exciting story about a badass heroine it
started airing on august 14th so go and
watch the first episode right now let's
embark on an epic journey across the
high seas together and i hope that
you'll enjoy watching this show
crunchyroll also grants a 14-day free
trial of their premium membership so
what are you waiting for follow the link
in the description sign up and start
watching anime oh and before we get back
to the main video i'd like to give you a
preview of the show with this trailer
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
now let's get on with the show we kick
things off we're tacked off destiny
[Music]
our first show takes us to america in
the near future after a black meteorite
fell creatures called d2 appear to take
over the world banning the one thing
that could defeat them music in order to
exercise their iron grip on this world
standing against them are the music art
women who hold the power of music led by
the conductor now i'm pretty sure it
won't end up like any of the shows but
people have compared it to the fate
series in terms of aesthetics personally
vv was the first thing that came to my
mind because of the music backdrop along
with the premise of a fast-paced action
series featuring badass waifus all in
all it looks more like a commercial for
the upcoming smartphone game but with
mapa manning the helm i'm sure that
we'll get a good one here i'm really
eager to see how this one pans out and
if this original anime would kick the
tac-dom franchise off with a bang
[Music]
ninth on the list is faraway paladin
[Music]
paladin is probably the last thing that
crosses your mind when you think of
william mary blood an adventurer raised
by three undead he soon feels that there
must be more to life than what he has as
a resident of the land of the dead thus
he goes on his journey or with the
ever-pressing question in his mind who
am i so who did he come to be what
mysteries await in this strange land the
road to him being a full-fledged paladin
is long but with it comes a whole slew
of secrets that will seek to uncover in
his journey of self-discovery yeah i
tried to hide it when talking about the
show but the far away paladin is
surprise surprise and isakai and
probably the best new one will be
getting this for the premise makes it
out to be an isakai with a bigger focus
on characterization and world building
and those pretty much show the good
things that the series has to offer it
also features an overpowered main
character but he's one who carries a lot
of emotional burden within him and it
was fun seeing him strive to overcome
those in the manga overall a good show
to pick up if you're a fan of some
issachai and fantasy this fall
next up we have platinum end seven
[Music]
they're back from the creators of death
note comes this series looking to make
waves in the anime community platinum
and stars mirai living with abusive
relatives he'd sought to take his own
life but his attempt at doing so gets
thoughted by nasa his guardian angel who
comes to him with another proposition
why not become god thus mirai finds
himself with supernatural powers and
thrust into a battle royale of epic
proportions his goal defeat 12 are the
god candidates within 999 days in doing
so he'll attain unmatched power that he
can only dream of platinum demand in
terms of execution seems to be a big
departure from the more cerebral takes
the death note had it's also nowhere
near the sports manga-like feel that i
got from bakuman nevertheless i found
myself completely gripped and excited
for the succeeding developments in this
battle royale by the creators of two
series that i've loved i'm very excited
to see those gripping conflicts come to
life in anime form and hope that you
check the show out too
[Music]
sixth in line is the fourth season of
data live
[Music]
seeing this gave me about nostalgia and
i was loving these supernatural fantasy
harems that were so prevalent early last
decade i didn't think the day to life
would reach a fourth season in a genre
of mostly one and done date alive
trudges its way into the current decade
with its fourth season looking to
continue shido's conquest of dating
girls saving the world and slowly
uncovering the mysteries that surround
the space quakes and the existence of
spirits this time the focus is on two
new spirits nia and mukuro what stories
away shido as he continues his quest to
save the world through the power of love
data life has lived into its second
decade mostly backed by its popularity
and the series uncanny ability to
smoothly transition from studio to
studio this will be the fourth season of
the show under its full studio really
hoping for a full adaptation of the
anime with how close we are to the
ending of the light novel series the
finish line is in sight and business is
about to pick up sir
[Music]
fifth on the list is blue period
every season or so we get these
meaningful cnn shows for those who
prefer the more down-to-earth topics
that anime can shine a bright light on
these tend to be more artistic and or
inspirational for this reason my pick
for that subcategory or archetype is
blue period it tells the story of a boy
yatora who's bored with the monotomy and
predictability of his own life that
changes when he stumbles upon the one
thing that brings color to his life art
using painting as his medium of
conveying his thoughts he soon grows in
love with the craft and looks to pursue
it however problems await such as
disapproving parents and the complexity
of art that most ordinary people don't
recognize blue period overall is a very
relatable show that deals with scenarios
i'm sure a whole lot of us had gone
through or are currently going through
after reading some of it i also like the
series for how it tackles some aspects
of art that we rarely see every day and
it does so while giving us some very
captivating interactions between
characters probably not going to be a
mainstream hit this season but it will
truly be remembered as a hidden gem
the third season of world trigger is
coming and it's the fourth ranked entry
on our list
it's been a long journey since around
that mid point of last decade but after
a dazzling second season just last
winter will trigger set to return for a
third season actually i think the formal
term of third season is just a misnomer
you know how these prods just like
splitting a core into two and calling it
half a season yeah that with the way
things are going we should be seeing the
end of the rank wars where this core is
done and it's one of the more
anticipated parts of the manga so i'll
be looking forward to see how that gets
adapted besides the progression of the
plot world trigger has managed to look
better with each season which is a
rarity for most shows and more of a
testament of the care being put into its
anime adaptation just look at some of
the fights including the one that i
featured not so long ago there's a lot
to be excited for especially if you're a
world trigger fan and we're going to be
seeing each other this fall
[Music]
third on our list is gomi can't
communicate
[Music]
oh how long i've waited for this for as
long as i can remember this is one of
the series that people have been
clamoring for an anime adaptation well
2021 is here to grant you your wish and
komi-san will finally be appearing in
anime forum to entertain all of us with
her antics i've been reading the manga
as well and i found myself thoroughly
enjoying the dynamic between comey and
tardano the meeting and developing
friendship between two socially awkward
students who turn out to be not so
different after all may not seem that
unique at first but gomi-san as the
series has executed it so well i've
heard comparisons to series like garguya
or horomia but komi-san brings something
new to the table that you can all enjoy
in anime form this fall be sure to check
out this hit series that's finally gonna
get its much deserved anime
they sure kept you waiting didn't they
mushoku 10 says continuation is finally
here
i still remember the buzz like it was
just yesterday we had people getting so
hyped and everyone eagerly awaited for
the continuation to probably one of the
best traditional isekai japan has to
offer then delay ah the number one enemy
of the anime fan thankfully it seems
that the team's got all those wrinkles
out of the way and we're ready to get
the ball rolling it did take him long
enough but we can finally see the rest
of rudy's adventures with his group in
the demon continent let's all hope that
the actual product makes the delay well
worth it given what the team showed us
in the first part of the show i've got
full confidence that they brought their
a game in bringing us this next part to
the hit series knock on wood but i
haven't heard about any production
issues or internal drama so we should be
all good
the jojo train continues with our next
entry
better late than never the latest anime
announced in the roster is none other
than jojo's bizarre adventure part 6
stone ocean after the success of gold
and wind in the franchise in general
stone ocean's announcement didn't really
come as a surprise after all if you've
adapted five parts already why not cap
it off with the finale of the original
continuity this time the story set in
2011 where the spotlight falls on jolene
cujo jotaro's daughter after she gets
framed for murder jotaro manages to
awaken her stand and tell her of the
future only to have those memories be
stolen by dio's trusty follower father
enrico pucci allying herself with
inmates and a rag tagged bunch of allies
jolene sets forth to stop father poochie
will she and the group be able to save
the world from being remade in dio's
image what can we say the promotional
material we've got looks really awesome
and fitting for such a storied franchise
and it's the culmination of an epic saga
it's been a long journey but it all
comes to a head here with the final
battle between jotaro and dia rolling to
its final conclusion through their
spiritual successors it's a grand ending
that any jojo fan wouldn't want to miss
it's time to settle the generation feud
once and for all
we all know it's inevitable demon slayer
is getting a second season and is set to
take the world by storm this fall
[Music]
with how much of a runaway success
everything demon slay has been from the
tv series the manga the movie and
everything in between the second season
is just inevitable i don't think i've
seen a phenomenon as big and
all-encompassing as this ever since
attack on titan more modern stuff that
locals compared to the craze like madoka
sao or one punch man never had that big
and all-encompassing of a peak for sure
after the thrilling ride there was
infinity train tanjiro and his ragtag
group of allies take to the red light
district this time they're sent as
assistance for tengen uzui the sound
pillar who's on a mission to rescue his
three wives facing them is a pair of
upper moons who are more than meets the
eye with all those combustible elements
converging in the red light district
we're set to have a battle royale of
insane proportions having read the manga
my expectations are sky high and i fully
predict demon slayer season 2 to
continue enchanting us with epic action
and drama
that ends the list and if you enjoyed
the video you might want to check out
the channel for more anime countdowns as
always hit that like button if you had
fun and if you're up for supporting
vinitu for more content you can always
check out the channel's membership
options or my patreon don't forget to
check out fenner pirate princess on
crunchyroll for free or try a 14 day
free trial of their premium membership
follow the link in the description to
start watching that's it for today and i
hope to see you on the next list thank
you for watching and have fun out there
[Music]
you